[Music]
you know talking about spoilers one
thing i always do is i never read
geek press you know so if you know
there's like when a movie's coming out i
don't want to know anything about the
plot because there's always plot
spoilers or such and such as in the
movie i try
to really um yeah
and it really [ __ ] me once
really screwed me over i was living in
san francisco in the san francisco
cinema society they did a viewing of a
movie called bottle shock right
okay you guys probably never heard of
bottle shock is a little tiny indie
movie it was entertaining i loved it you
know so
you know that i think it was uh the the
director is there and one of the stars
of the show so we all you know it was
the same aside we always chat with
everybody nobody knew anybody from
anybody
but what i didn't know
was the one uh the the guy that played
beau barrett which was
at this uh
at this whining cheese party for bottle
shock
was [ __ ] chris pine and he just
rapped
re i know right and he just snapped on
the jj abrams first star trek film i had
no idea who he was oh my god
we're talking about you know what it's
like to film in napa what's his favorite
wine do you know how many hangovers he
had that was what was i did it
he was such a good cook as well yeah so
wait there's so many people coming they
reckon that's it
we're gonna get another jj abrams star
trek we think
it was it was off the cards for a long
time but it looks like it might i'm
gonna tentative he didn't he did a damn
in my opinion a damn fine job like i
mean
like
better than discovery did in terms of
upgrading the technology but keeping it
similar
um you know uh
yeah it was a different team dynamic but
it was a team nomadic i enjoyed you know
like it didn't deviate too far they i
mean they did the same thing with the
klingons you were talking earlier on
about the
redesign where it came from i think
it was yeah i mean it was basically
other than the double nostril is
basically the same thing
class classic star trek as far as i'm
concerned i thought it was yeah yeah
yeah
i loved it um but once again i hate to
say this guys we haven't talked about
star wars yet
no no but we can let's
just say let's just keep it like
we've got to keep our brains in one
place
there's so many there's so many
crossovers between the issues with the
two that's all i'm saying but like jay
you're you're you're okay you're doing
your name no no we'll we we are co-hosts
and if you are willing to draw all over
your face for this episode then you are
allowed to uh to take the lead
occasionally i didn't i didn't think it
was permanent but i'm going to be
committed
yeah i've got i'm going to have a very
very awkward week next week with um the
council in the nhs but who cares i'm
good
don't walk into a hospital jesus christ
a new variant of covert
they might like
get a tattooed on
[Music]